hola a todos cómo están muy buenas
noches hoy voy a empezar haciendo un
pequeño ejercicio así es que es momento
de que participen la escribí tienes como
fiesta infantil
yo creo que levanten la mano todos
aquellos que esta última semana tomaron
su teléfono en algún momento entraron a
cualquier red social y estuvieron ahí
tres minutos menos como cinco y dijeron
no ya el mundo acaba de bailar que eso
se fue para el perro que nos lleven los
extraterrestres yo voy a ser el primero
levantar la banda de ayuda pero bueno
está comentó que todos dijimos eso esta
semana yo levanté la mano y sí la verdad
es que está muy complicado creo que
entregar redes sociales en estos días
está a nada de considerarse un deporte
extremo porque ya entrega y requiere de
mucha fuerza de voluntad y la verdad es
que irnos a dormir después de la
cantidad de información negativa que
estamos leyendo ahí viendo acabar con
pesadillas ya está imposible pero
totalmente imposible se acuerdan los que
tenemos un poquito de edad tal vez
de esas películas de finales de los 90
en las que se aproximaba el desastre y
entonces era la tierra y había un cometa
que está surcando el cielo y estaba a
punto de colapsar con la tierra y al
mismo tiempo había una tormenta de nieve
y la lluvia se desbordaba un río y
explotar un volcán todo esto mientras
estábamos a punto de ser conquistados
por una raza extraterrestre bueno todo
eso es un cuento de hadas comparado con
lo que está pasando en el mundo en estos
momentos la verdad es que si todo lo que
pasa en este momento aquí afuera en el
mundo está complicadísimo pero la verdad
es que nosotros no lo estamos haciendo
mejor en redes sociales estamos tal vez
complicando un poquito las cosas
y que hoy vamos a hacer un poquito de
memoria me voy a poner como tío ya saben
tío en navidad que se pone a recordar lo
que pasaba antes y los buenos tiempos y
demás vamos a hacer memoria e irnos unos
diez años para atrás y recordamos como
usábamos las redes sociales hace diez
años no es tanto tiempo y al mismo
tiempo ya llovió no yo imagino que
muchos de ustedes y no se hagan andaban
llegando por ahí en alguna red social
consiguieron a su novia a su novio o
probablemente se pusieron un día
intercambiar canciones con una persona
que vivía en el otro extremo del mundo
tal vez un día se desvelaron chateando
con una persona que hablaba otro idioma
puede que algunos hayan conseguido
trabajo también a mí me pasó alguna vez
me puse a leer un blog y terminé
inspirado para cambiar cosas en mi vida
eso eran las redes sociales al inicio
para eso se crearon para conectarnos
para unirnos como sociedades para
acortar distancias
pero regresando a esta época que estamos
viviendo ahorita como que algo pasó en
el camino hubo 20 tropezones y las redes
cambiaron ese sentido y en este momento
se convirtieron en todo lo contrario
mientras que originalmente las redes se
trataban de que nuestras diferencias
fueran mínimas y fuera más lo que nos
unía en este momento es todo lo
contrario para que siga ser que es más
importante decir y mostrar todo lo que
no se paga como sociedad es a lo que nos
une y pues está terrible y está súper
deprimente lo que estoy diciendo y la
verdad me la voy a jugar les voy a decir
yo creo que esto no es una mala noticia
y siguiente amanecer así como no gusto
busto terrible luego que no es normal la
noticia
no creo que es una mala noticia del todo
porque lo veo como una oportunidad
tenemos en este momento un momento de
cambio en el que podemos decidir y
cambiar las cosas y volver a las redes
sociales al sentido original que tenían
que conectarnos unirnos que nuestras
similitudes pesaban más que nuestras
diferencias
si el mundo está muy complicado allá
afuera y probablemente solemos echarle
la culpa a gobiernos a empresas a otro
tipo de poderes por toda la porquería
que pasa y si es cierto tienen muchísima
responsabilidad pero también en nosotros
cabe mucha esa responsabilidad y porque
lo digo porque las redes sociales son
nuestras nosotros las hacemos posibles
el contenido que está ahí lo jugamos
nosotros y somos nosotros quienes
tomamos la decisión de compartir algo o
no compartiendo cambiar el mundo puede
sonar muy disparatado y uno de esos
sueños que dices quiero cambiar el mundo
la verdad es que tenemos una herramienta
en la palma de nuestras manos que es
esto de acá que si lo sabemos usar bien
puede impactar a millones de personas y
puede generar cambios que ni siquiera
imaginamos el sentido de los mensajes
que compartimos en redes sociales
depende 100% de nosotros puede ser
positivo o negativo
ahí es donde tomamos la decisión y
podrías abajo y yo quiero invitarlos a
que a partir de hoy seamos un poquito
más conscientes
de lo que estamos compartiendo porque
compartir algo puede arruinarle la vida
a una persona oa una familia oa una
sociedad y eso está terrible y mientras
sigamos separados como sociedad y
enfrentados no vamos a poder lograr los
cambios que tenemos por eso a mí se me
ocurrieron tres cositas fáciles que
podemos empezar a hacer desde hoy por
empezar a cambiar este sentido de la
conversación y este ciclo tan feo en el
que ya nos metimos la primera se llama
micrófono apagado de qué se trata
micrófono apagado si entra ahorita
cualquier red nos vamos a topar un
montón de mensajes de odio que les
parece que dejamos de amplificar los
muchas veces sin querer incluso por
buena onda compartimos un mensaje de
odio para descalificarlo
resulta que al compartirlo le estamos
dando un mayor difusión y creo que es un
mensaje de odio no merece ser replicado
no merece ser amplificado
dejemos los mensajes pues ahí en la
esquina y que nadie los pena la ciudad
de acción que les propongo se llama
cuéntame más de qué se trata cuenta
demás
afortunadamente vivimos en un mundo de
una sociedad donde todos pensamos
diferente que para qué flojera que todos
pensábamos igual que tiempo cosa que la
siguiente vez que te topes a alguien en
alguna red que piensa distinto a ti
antes de atacarlo descalificarlo
menospreciarlo tácticas un ratito con
esa persona igual y resulta que esa
persona está viendo el mundo desde un
punto de vista que tú ni siquiera sabías
todavía es considerado castigo el
terminas aprendiendo algo nuevo y
haciendo un nuevo amigo y por último tan
amigos como siempre y de que matando
amigos como siempre pues igual que
conociste alguien que piensa
radicalmente diferente a ti y no lo vas
a cambiar y eso está increíble eso no
significa que no puedas tener una buena
relación o pueden ser amigos o
simplemente conocidos y respetar los
distintos puntos de vista tampoco se
trata de descalificar a los demás
es momento de que las plataformas
sociales en las que estamos están
enfrentados en este momento evolucionen
y evolucionen a plataformas a
comunidades en donde nuestras cosas que
nos hacen similares pesen más que lo que
nos divide eso nos va a llevar a tener
sociedades más fuertes más unidas y son
ese tipo de sociedades las que cambian
mundos muchas gracias y muy buenas
noches
[Aplausos]